here at Keating Labs we're going to do
an experiment
[Music]
if ice made from
or water that is with two hydrogen atoms
and one oxygen atom will float as well
as it does on liquid water as it does on
deuterium oxide this dollar per
milliliter fluid that I had to special
order let's see if the ice floating here
on ordinary water will float the same
way or change in some way when we try to
float our ordinary ice water on top of
deuterium or heavy water
less pour the deuterium water in to this
container and see if it will float an
ice cube in exactly the same way that
ordinary hydrogen dihydrogen oxide did
with ordinary hydrogen
so this is sinking and this is more no
it does float it floats better
[Music]
so put it in side by side here's the
deuterium oxide which is more dense than
ordinary liquid water over here and you
see our calibrated ice cubes are
floating better in the deuterium oxide
than they are in the ordinary water
because this is more dense this is more
buoyant relative to the liquid it will
float better so there's more of the
iceberg mini Iceberg exposed here and it
floats actually better
so there you have it deuterium oxide
expensive more tasty and better for
flotation purposes but beware it's a lot
more expensive to get your hands on this
water than to go down to Starbucks and
get a cup of venti ice water
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're going to answer the opposite
question does a deuterium Iceberg float
on top of ordinary water let's check it
out heating Labs deionized water hashtag
not sponsored fill up ordinary water
here ordinary water in this
and then here's my dollar per milliliter
deuterium oxide or heavy water that was
used to make this ice cube over here in
just about as much time as it took to
make these ice cubes of ordinary water
here's an ordinary ice cube made of
ordinary dihydrogen oxide that floats
just fine as ordinary ice floats on top
of ordinary water
see that guy moving around now the
question is well
so here's the
deuterium oxide Ice Cube that's a little
harder to get out
that will flow this is a big boy
no sinks right to the Bottom now I know
what you're thinking maybe if it was in
the other petri dish it would float just
fine let's try it take a deuterium oxide
heavy water Ice Cube and see if it
floats it should if it was ordinary
water but no it sinks right to the
bottom
so this expensive drink on the Rocks
Won't cool off as fast as your ordinary
ice would but be careful each Ice Cube
cost about fifty dollars to make
[Music]
[Music]